see we have a hexagon here and if we
want to find out if this has rotational
symmetry meaning that you know if we
turn this object will it match up with
itself one nice technique is is to look
at the lines of symmetry so what a line
of symmetry is it's a line okay of
course that when you fold it over that
line the figure maps to itself so this
has one line of symmetry like this but
you could also draw a line of symmetry
like this okay we could fold it this way
if you draw a line of symmetry like this
you can fold it this way and you can
also go through the vertices like so so
that would be four five and six so
there's six lines of symmetry if we take
360 degrees divided by the six lines of
symmetry you can see we're getting sixty
degrees so what that means is that if we
rotate about this point sixty degrees
it's just like a knob this object will
match up with itself so we can say this
has 60 degree rotational symmetry
okay example number two when we look at
this figure here
there aren't any lines of symmetry like
if I draw this like this let me let's
say on this angle like here if I fold it
over it doesn't actually match with this
figure here it's you know it it's it
doesn't match up perfectly I guess eyes
only way I can say it when you fold it
this is going to be pointing in a
slightly different direction and so this
one it's maybe not we can't really solve
with the way we did this one but you can
still see that if you were to take this
object and turn it a quarter turn 90
degrees that this you know flag or
triangle is gonna then match up with
this one this one's going to match up
with this one and so on and so by doing
it 90 degree turn a rotation this will
match to itself so this does have
rotational symmetry 90 degrees okay
third example here I've drawn a triangle
for us an isosceles triangle and you can
see that there's a line of symmetry that
goes right down the middle like so
meaning if we fold it over this line
it's going to match to itself well if we
go back to example number one where we
took 360 degrees and we divided it by
the number of lines of symmetry you can
see we're just getting 360 degrees well
360 degrees if you take any object and
you turn it all the way around okay a
full turn me actually it will match with
itself okay because you've done a
complete revolution
the same position it was in originally
so we don't consider this having any
rotational symmetry 360 doesn't count
it's going to be anything between 0 and
180 okay
it won't exceed that so 360 degrees
doesn't count so I hope this helped you
to understand how to work with
rotational symmetry and how to find that
angle of rotational symmetry
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other math videos on meros math
tutor and youtube channel and i look
forward to seeing in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon